Ich bin der Luftaufklärer und Auswerteunteroffizier bei der Luftaufklärung in Langenlebarn.
Meine Aufgaben umfassen die Planung und Durchführung von militärischen und auch zivilen Luftbild Aufträgen.
Wir beginnen mit der Flugvorbereitung, das heißt wir planen die Flüge,
gehen dann zusammen mit dem Piloten zum Fluggerät und führen anschließend unseren Auftrag durch.
Nach der Landung werden die Aufnahmen ausgewertet und an die jeweiligen Auftraggeber ausgeliefert.
Ich bin Hubschraubertechniker am Black Hawk, da fast jeden Tag der Hubschrauber zum Flugdienst verwendet wird,
ist es meine tägliche Aufgabe, die erste Kontrolle vor dem Flug durchzuführen.
Und auch den Piloten bei Übungen und Einsätzen bei der Landung einzuweisen bzw.
die Außenlast so einzuweisen, dass sie auf dem Punkt landet, wo sie letzten Endes sein soll.
Der Kaiowa ist der einzige bewaffnete Hubschrauber im österreichischen Bundesheer.
Daraus ergeben sich in weiterer Folge auch die Einsatzaufgaben.
Meine Aufgabe in der heutigen Übung ist der Begleitschutz des Black Hawks,
plus die Aufklärung des Marschweges und der Landezone
in der dann in weiterer Folge die Truppen und die Außenlast abgesetzt werden.